so what I want to do here is start a
series creating two characters against
each other one from Marvel Comics and
one from DC Comics and what we're going
to do here is use three categories to
present our case which will be
storylines powers or abilities and the
rogues gallery which is to say their
various villains and to start this off
we're going to be focusing on Batman and
Black Panther so as one of the original
comic book superheroes Batman's history
throws all the way back to the Golden
Age of comics in 1940 and as a result he
has a huge leeway on Black Panther in
terms of his story lines written by
Chuck Dixon 1993's nightfall saw Bruce
Wayne removed from his role as Batman
for the first time in publication
history after his back was broken by
Bane leading to fan favorite Dick
Grayson undertaking the mantle for time
The Killing Joke by Alan Moore stands as
a classic story and that it provided a
bit of Joker's origin but also went
towards the mental torment of Jim Gordon
at the hands of the Joker as well as the
inclusion which has been debated
constantly regarding whether Batman
killed Joker or not finally The Dark
Knight Returns by Frank Miller is hailed
as the definitive Batman story that
focused on a dystopian future with Bruce
Wayne coming out of retirement but also
because it shifted Batman to overtaking
Superman in popularity due to its dark
and gritty nature and by extension move
the comic-book industry into a new era
referred to as the Dark Age which
focused on dark stories and the deaths
of popular characters now for Black
Panther the first five issues of 1998's
vol 3 under the Marvel Knights imprint
is widely considered to be the best and
most important run for both his
character and his fans what I mean here
is that this story was entry level
allowing readers who knew of the
character but have no knowledge of his
history to jump into the series this was
compounded on by the fact that
Christopher priests expanded onto Chavez
roots in Wakanda and that he focused
heavily on the religion of the wakandans
and the perception of like Panther as
their leader and spiritual guide the
Secret Invasion tie-in titled the might
of Wakanda covered in Black Panther vol
4 issues 39 40 and 41 focused on the
idea that no one had ever successfully
conquered the nation of Wakanda with
Secret Invasion seeing the scrolls
infiltrating and replacing over 90% of
Earth's population both human and
super-powered
the might of Wakanda focused on their
efforts
to subvert and take over the fictional
city where the casualties were high and
the population was almost completely
obliterated the story is absolutely
gripping and a fascinating demonstration
of how far to Chawla and his wife storm
were willing to go to protect their
people so in terms of abilities
Batman is routinely depicted as one of
the top three smartest people on the
planet along with Lex Luthor and mr.
terrific and his wealth is well
documented and that it provides him with
the financial backing necessary to fund
his endeavors the Batcave the Batmobile
and the batwing all stand as icons of
his comics to say nothing of the various
items within his utility belt which
allow him to cope with virtually any
situation however much like Batman
T'Challa was born into an empire but
where Bruce's Empire was metaphorical
and under the banner of Wayne industries
Black Panther exists as the leader of a
literal Empire in Wakanda which exists
as a refuge of technological advancement
having said that because Marvel's most
intelligent beings consist of Reed
Richards dr. doom and Valeria Richards
who simultaneously occupy first place
black panther himself is largely
considered to be one of the smartest
people on the planet behind Tony Stark
Amadeus Cho or Peter Parker but again
this is usually based on the stories
writer at the time finally where Bruce
Wayne's skillset comes from his enhanced
intelligence and mastery of multiple
martial arts disciplines
black panther's abilities hail from his
exposure to the Panther deity and the
various powers that come with it as such
his sense of smell is on par with Wolf's
reign allowing him to detect a scent and
never lose it in addition to all of his
physical attributes being elevated to
the same levels as Captain America now
in truth Batman's villains are where his
character really outclasses Black
Panther the Joker is a classic here and
is routinely ranked as the greatest
villain of all time
across almost all sites dedicated to
geek culture whether it be his love for
violence in chaos as seen in 1988 to
death in the family when he beat Jason
Todd to death with a crowbar or the
downright silliness of his schemes like
1978's Detective Comics number 475 which
saw him trying to copyright fish the
Joker is a fan favorite with interest
perking up the instant he makes an
appearance in comics
conversely Bane and Riddler challenge
Batman physically and mentally
often times pushing him to his limits
this combined with events like Tower of
Babel where Rochelle ghoul had stolen
the protocols on the rest of the Justice
League leading to their individual
defeats and the destruction of their
trust and Batman demonstrate that his
rogues gallery consists of some of the
most dangerous and unpredictable beings
on the planet black panther doesn't
really have his own rogue's gallery
aside from ulysses klaw who's more of a
nuisance than an actual threat while
most of this is due to the fact that the
citizens of Wakanda Revere T'Challa with
love more than fear meaning that very
few of them would actually rise up
against him it's also because his
escapades in the coming of universe stem
from his involvement with the Avengers
and the various threats they face and so
with all that being said I'm leaving it
to you guys to decide which character do
you think is better Bruce Wayne or black
panther with that being said I will
catch you guys later
purse